[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUKE STONE: I know it's
kind of getting close
to the end of the whole Next,
and I've got a lot of stuff
to talk about today.
What you should never do is
name your talk "10" of anything,
right?
Maybe a handful or
a few or some, but
really don't commit yourself to
like a big number or anything.
So we might go kind of fast, and
hopefully I'll keep you awake
after lunch.
My name is Luke Stone.
I am from the Customer
Reliability Engineering team,
and what we are is
we are Google SRE--
that's Site Reliability
Engineering--
for your applications.
So today we're going to
talk about 10 common causes
of downtime and
how to avoid them.
So this is-- first, I just want
to get into just the ground
rules of what we'll
talk about today,
because this is a
pretty big topic.
It's kind of like
complementary to Miles's words
talk the other day that he
did to the IT and ops track
about how to make and run
reliable applications.
This one is for app developers,
and it's really about
thinking about how you can
design your applications
and the features you
want to put in them so
that your applications stay
resilient automatically.
And you don't have to yell at
your operator to go fix it.
So I'm going to present
just a list of 10 things
that I've seen in my
experience, and we'll
go over some ideas about
how to prevent them.
These are not really--
these are not things that
you'll see everywhere,
but these are things
that I've seen myself.
So a little bit about me.
I've been at Google since 2002.
I started off, and I came
in doing technical support
for AdSense partners.
This was one of Google's
first partnership types,
where it was a
technology partnership.
We sent ads to our partners over
XML feeds over the internet,
and they put the ads
on their website.
And then we shared the money.
And it worked really well.
But it needed to
be up all the time.
And it really taught
me this lesson
that if you're in a
technology partnership,
the thing needs to be up.
Both teams are responsible
for it being up all the time.
It didn't do me any good to
point my finger at the partner
when the ads were down.
We just had to work
together to get it up.
I've been in GCP since 2014.
I started off in GCP running
the tech support org.
That's you guys.
Yeah.
And we do great
tech support at GCP.
And we have really
good engineers,
who are 24 by seven
doing tech support.
And what I found during
those couple of years
of running tech
support was that when
people are looking for
really high reliability
like four nines, five
nines, you kind of
can't get that if
you have to file
a ticket with tech support.
That costs a couple of minutes.
If you have four nines,
it's four minutes a month
of downtime.
So you're blown away as soon
as you're filing a ticket.
So we need to think
about how we can
make the application reliable,
automate recovery, be
resilient, auto-heal,
so we don't
have to ever file a ticket.
And that's why we
invented CRE, which
is Customer Reliability
Engineering, so we
could get this done.
So basically,
outages like this--
you can see, of
course, for a second
you start falling of a cliff.
And the latency goes
to basically the max.
That kind of outage
that you might have
once a year, that's my day job.
So if I can see all these
different outages, spots
and patterns, and then
share with you guys,
I think I can provide
some pretty good value.
So what we'll talk
about today is not
super secret or anything.
A lot of it is basic
distributed systems stuff,
but you need to think about
the stuff, even the basics,
and really do every
single thing that you
know is going to break
your application before it
does break your application.
And we also have to think
about not waiting for ops
to come along and clean
up afterwards and not
get to a spot, where oh,
we ran out of computers.
I need to like call ops and
get some more computers.
Your application needs
to be built in such a way
that it can provision more
resources when it needs to.
It can notice when it's
at capacity or it's down.
So the first priority is keep
serving traffic all the time.
Keep serving traffic.
And then raise an alert, so
someone can come and remediate
the situation later.
But do some graceful
degradation.
And also, these things are not
super tied to GCP products.
This is broadly
applicable on prem
or on another public cloud.
Also, these are just kind of
generic patterns that we see.
And there's no
reliability product.
Reliability is just a result
of lots of hard work, lots
of planning, having really good
design, and good practices.
You can't just go buy
the reliability button.
This is actually pretty
different on public cloud
than it is on prem.
There's actually a lot
of companies out there
that will just try to
sell you reliability
for money with appliances
that you can buy on prem.
But that's not really how
it works in public cloud.
So you need to change
your thinking a little bit
away from this scale
up, and we'll just
add four more redundant
power supplies
and this kind of thing.
And think about how
we're going to scale out,
how we're going to anticipate
that nodes are going
to go down, and we'll
be able to notice that
and recover automatically.
OK.
So we'll think about an
example application, of course.
How can you do
this kind of thing
without any kind of example?
Imagine you're a Muppet,
and this is your app.
OK.
Here's this architecture
just to lay it out.
It's pretty simple.
We have an API backend
that we're developing.
We have some users that
are represented by the U.
We have a load balancer.
That's the LB.
Your API backend is the A.
This is kind of the thing
that you're coding.
And then you have an
external service, which is--
I call that a Vision API.
It could be something,
but you're calling to it,
and it's not under your control.
I made the sizes of
the dots represent
the capacity of that node.
So if its users kind
of think about-- it's
enough users to generate
100,000 queries per second.
And queries per second is a
terminology we use in Google.
It comes from our
days in search,
where people were doing queries.
So a lot of people say
requests per second.
We just use this term,
queries per second.
So the size of the
nodes is capacity,
and the size of the edges is
traffic flowing along them.
So if the edge gets bigger
than the dot, we're in trouble.
Think about that,
and if the edge gets
a lot smaller than the
dot, that means we're not
serving to our capacity.
And that's probably
a problem also.
So number one cause of downtime
is you just get overloaded.
You have a success disaster.
Imagine you launch a
really great video game,
and people really
like it 50 times more
than you thought they would.
This happens all
the time on cloud,
because we have really
great networking and scaling
all around your application.
So where you may
be used to on prem
have a little drinking straw
firewall or load balancer
in front of you or little
drinking straw internet
connection, that will shield
you from all sorts of load
problems.
You just kind of don't see
them, because the packets
get dropped outside, and
users are complaining.
But as an application
developer, you'd never know it.
On our cloud, it's
really different,
because the load balancer
is super happy to send you
millions of queries per second.
It loves to do that.
The firewall is distributed.
As you probably know, if you've
read the Andromeda paper,
the firewall is distributed, and
it's actually on all the hosts.
So it can take any
amount of traffic.
And the network is really
well-connected to the internet,
so you really don't
get into a situation
where users can't
reach you, because you
don't have bandwidth.
So here in this scenario,
I've made the users
three times as big.
They went to 300,000 QPS.
Now your application
is getting overwhelmed.
It can't keep up with demand.
It can only actually make 10,000
QPS back to the Vision API.
So all of a sudden, this becomes
your effective throughput,
as you can only
do 10,000 QPS back
to the users of useful work,
because you're sitting here
dying under all their load.
So I hope you can see that.
At the bottom of
the screen, you can
see the node that's selected
has a blue circle around it.
And you can see the edges
coming out of there.
So what do you do about
an overload scenario?
Do you call the ops person and
say, hey, add more servers?
That's going to
take a lot of time.
There's no way.
So what you need to think about
is, I'm going to shed the load.
I've got to get rid of
load that I can't possibly
serve anyway so that I can serve
a little more valuable work.
So think about the types
of traffic you're getting.
If there's a type that's not
as valuable as some other type,
maybe like toss that
on the ground first.
Just very quickly
serve an error,
because you're trying to just
defend yourself at this point,
just trying to get
rid of enough work
that you can do some useful
work and not just die.
So one way to
think about this is
to just calculate the
capacity of your service
like using the
load test or math,
and figure out, OK, if I can do
100,000 QPS at my application
server, then everything
over 100,000--
I'm just going to
keep a counter--
and everything over
100,000, I'm just
going to return an
error just immediately.
And it's going to cost
virtually nothing.
Then at least you're
serving some useful work.
So it's a way to
artificially increase
the capacity of your
service, and you can actually
serve a nice error
to a user that
tells them something better
than just like TCP timeout.
It's pretty good.
So the problem
here is that we're
serving nice errors to our
user, and we're saying,
yeah, our site's
having a problem,
and there's like a little
sad Tweety Bird or something.
But we're still only getting
100,000 QPS of useful work out
of the Vision API.
So it's not great, but we're
still serving some traffic.
And it's not the
end of the world.
So that brings us
to our next cause
of downtime, which is that
you get a noisy neighbor.
You did all this
nice work to compute
that your service can handle
100,000 QPS at the application
layer.
But you forgot about
the fact that you're
going to be running a backup
script on that server.
And that's going to take
up a lot of-- that's going
to take up a bunch of cycles.
Or you have users, and as
soon as you have users,
you get spam.
And you're going to
get spammy users,
and I guarantee you'll be
shocked at the size of the spam
compared to the size
of the real users.
I mean, it's very
easy for the spam
to go 10x the normal volume
of the actual human users.
So you really need to protect
yourself against this stuff.
So if we just shed load
evenly just AB, AB,
and we're just going
to decide to shed,
then we're going to actually
impact our real users
a lot more than we need to,
because we can actually be
a little bit smarter about it.
And we can decide which
queries to throw away.
So the way to think about
dealing with noisy neighbors
is you put in place limits,
like you say, artificially
limit each user ID is going
to get 100 queries per second.
I can't imagine a human user
would do more than 100 queries
per second.
And that really helps, because
a lot of the spambots, bad guys,
will be sending 100,000
queries per second.
And that's really more
than is reasonable.
It's easy to detect.
Some people try to
do stuff like do it
by IP address or something.
But you have to check
your assumptions
a little bit about
how distributed
the load is across IP space.
If you have something like a
cookie that you're giving out,
then you know a little bit
more about the distribution
of the keyspace.
So using user ID,
using a cookie ID,
using some hash of a
bunch of information
that you can get
from the HTTP request
is a pretty useful
way to keep counters
on how many queries
people are allowed to do,
and then cut them off when
they hit their limit just
to protect others.
So it's also good to
do this in combination
with a lot of different
similar strategies
like limit the cookie to
100 queries per second,
and then maybe limit
each IP address
to 100,000 queries per second.
And then maybe limit each--
I don't know-- user agent
to 100,000 or something.
And then you can kind of
build a layered situation,
where it's likely that you'll
take out a bad guy before they
get all the way through.
But inevitably, you're going
to take out some good guys too.
You'll still be serving
90% of the good guys,
so that's good news.
But somebody will
complain, and they'll say,
hey, you took down my IP
address, and I'm really mad.
Why can't I access your service?
So make sure that you make
these things configurable,
and don't just like hardcode
it into your code, where you'd
have to deploy new code in
order to restore service
to your users.
Make it configurable, so you
can just push up a new file,
and let them back in.
Most users will say,
yeah, I'm bummed,
but you said you were sorry,
and you fixed it right away,
so thank you so much.
They don't really
like it if you just
say, I have to leave you out
of service for a week because
of technical issues
on my side, because I
have to burn a new release.
They don't care.
And you also can just alert
again to your ops team,
and whack the mole later
by pushing a firewall rule
or something up to a higher
layer, so it's cheaper to serve
or cheaper to reject
the bad traffic.
First things first, though,
is just protect the service,
protect the good
users, and keep going.
So what happens when you
start rejecting people?
Well, they retry,
because they don't
know why they're rejected.
So retry spikes are
a pretty famous way
to generate a lot of load.
And when you're dealing with
a micro service architecture,
it's pretty different,
because each layer
is retrying to the next layer.
So you can get this compounding
effect pretty quickly.
I've just illustrated here
300,000 QPS provisioned
at the API server, and the
users turns into 2.7 million
after it gets compounded
three times by the client.
Then the load balancer
is retrying again,
and you can imagine what happens
if you put caching layers
and stuff in between here.
It can get out of
hand really fast.
So watch out for
your retry spikes,
because this is the most common
cause of a cascading failure.
Some little part of it goes
down, and then everybody piles
on and tries to get more,
really crushes that thing.
And they move over to the
next zone or region, whatever
your deployment unit
is, crush that thing,
and nobody can get back
up, because there's
just so much noise
from all the retries.
So what do you do about retries?
Well, this is about the
client and the server
actually being
polite to each other.
A lot of it has to
do with the client.
If you can control the
client, you're very lucky.
Usually, this is a mobile
application scenario.
You can control the
client a little bit.
There's a lot of time-honored
techniques of doing backoff,
and we did a CRE
blog about backoff.
The classic is like exponential
backoff with [? jitter ?].
There's kind of no reason
that exponential backoff
is the right amount.
There's no reason you
should wait one second, then
wait two seconds, then
wait four seconds.
Maybe wait one second, and
then you wait 10 seconds,
and then you wait a day.
It really depends
on your application.
Even with an exponential
backoff like of waiting
like one second, two
seconds, four seconds,
you're still getting three
retries within a few seconds.
It's unlikely that you've
actually fixed your service
in those few seconds.
So think about
having your backoff
in terms of the time that
you expect your service
to come back online.
There's also
signals you can send
to the client from the server.
You can say, hey, please try
again in an hour or tomorrow
or something like that.
There's an HTTP header called
Retry-After that nobody uses,
but you can.
When it becomes available in
browsers, then it'll work.
Another really
powerful technique
is to implement a retry
marker from the client.
So the client says, hey,
this is my first retry.
Hey, this is my second retry.
Put it in a URL parameter.
So then the server can
see it, and they can say,
OK, I'm going to decide
how to shed my load,
and I'm going to rank it by the
number of retries you've had.
So if you're on
your fifth retry,
probably you've already
given up anyway.
So I'll throw those away.
And then I'll throw away
all the four retries.
And then I'll throw
away all the thirds.
But I'll be really careful
to serve all the first ones
that I see.
So that's a pretty
powerful mechanism.
Another mechanism that's
useful as a last resort is
tar pitting, where what
you do in the server is you
just wait, and you introduce
some artificial latency
so that the clients
can't retry very fast.
So you basically try to use
up as much of their timeout
as you can get away with,
and then return to them.
Even if you're
returning an error,
you just wait, and then return.
So you're kind of stringing
them along a little bit.
But it's something you can
do purely on the server side
to slow down the
request velocity.
So we were going right along,
and we're serving nicely
until our Vision API, which
we thought could do 100,000
QPS, all of a sudden started
doing like 10,000 QPS,
because it just got really slow.
And we don't know why.
So now requests are piling
up at our API server,
and now we're
[? ooming ?], and now we're
not serving any traffic
back to the users.
This is just terrible.
The problem here really
is that the input
and the output of
your service are kind
of clueless about each other.
So the solution is to
make the logic that's
accepting incoming requests
be aware of its ability
to service those requests
via the external dependencies
on the backend.
So if I can only do 10,000
QPS of the Vision server,
I should really
only be accepting
10,000 QPS on the front end.
So the original load
shedding technique
that I suggested
of just deciding
that you could
serve 100,000 QPS,
and then just throwing away
everything after that, Adrian
Hilton, who's one
of our CREs, he
called that Procrustean
load shedding.
Procrustes was one
of Poseidon's sons,
who ran kind of a gloomy B and
B, where he had an iron bed.
And people would come, and
he would welcome them in.
He would say, oh,
I have a bed that
will fit you just perfectly.
And then if the poor sap was too
short, he would stretch them.
And if the poor sap was too
long, he would crush them.
And so it became a term that's
used for taking the problem
and fitting it to
a known constraint,
even if it doesn't
make any sense at all.
So luckily, Theseus came along
and dispatched him one day.
So we don't have
to worry about him.
But we still can't also rely
on that as a load shedding
technique, because when your
capacity kind of approaches
zero, then your assumption
that you could serve 100,000
QPS is wrong, and you
fall on your face.
So we need to think about being
really defensive in our client.
And your client needs to
become like a defensive driver.
Like leave a lot of space.
Make sure that you're
not going to overwhelm
your backend dependency,
and tell the upstream when
it's time to back off.
So you need to
think about what are
the timeouts that my clients are
making to me or having to me.
Like if they're going to
time out after one second,
don't set a three-second
timeout on your backend,
because by the time
you get an answer back,
your client's already gone away.
So you can work this through
in just your mental model
of how the system
works, and it's
very much cheaper than
figuring it out in real life.
And it's also
really nice to just
be able to just abort
your backend connection
after a second very cheaply if
the client's already gone away.
But how do you know when your
dependency's going to go away?
A lot of the dependencies
operate really,
really well most of the time.
So cloud storage
is a great example.
It often has tens of
milliseconds latency,
and it's four nines
for many weeks.
And then by design, someone
does some maintenance,
and it goes up to
80-millisecond latency and three
nines, which is like the
published SLA for it.
But if you've been
just relying on it
to work kind of how well it's
been working in the past,
then you'll be very surprised.
So what you want
to do with that is
do a disaster test,
where you simulate
the worst possible expected
behavior of the service.
So you can put in
logic in your client
to your backend that
artificially slows it
down and makes it look
like the backend is bad.
And then you can see
what your clients are
going to do to react to that.
So that's one technique.
And of course, just
doing good load tests
will often tease a
lot of this stuff out,
especially doing load tests
that are very sudden and spiky.
I mean, I know a lot of
people do load tests,
where they kind of
gradually ramp up the load.
And that's great, because
it's a very safe way
to do load tests that's unlikely
to come to find a problem.
But the purpose of
the load test is
to find the problem, so simulate
the scenario that you would
have if you had a zone
failover or something,
where you all of a sudden get
a huge instantaneous load.
That's the most fun
type of load test to do.
And you'll really
find the problems
before they occur in production.
The best possible
scenario to implement
is like a dynamic load
shedding, where you can actually
decide how much load to
shed on the front end
based on how your
back end is performing
and have some equilibrium
heuristic in your service
that can just
adapt all the time.
That way, you can kind of
get the best performance
and the best availability
all the time.
And one thing that's
kind of close to that
is being able to
at least manually
adjust your client parameters.
I know a lot of people just
put in retry three times
with a one-second timeout.
Just make it so that
you can configure those.
That can really
save your bacon when
your client is being
too aggressive to just
be able to push a
config very quickly.
Within a few minutes,
you can have your client
back off really nicely.
So all of that was in
the scenario of you
have one VM serving
your service.
And all of those things
are terrible things
that can happen to
your service no matter
how big it is when you
have 300,000 QPS of demand
and 100,000 QPS of
ability to serve it.
So let's say we actually want
to serve that 300,000 QPS.
The bottleneck here is
between our application
and this external API.
So what do we do?
We get a bigger VM, right?
That's not a very
good answer, actually.
So the cloud is really
built to scale out.
The thing that's different
with the public cloud from your
on prem is that we have
a really good network,
so adding new nodes
to the network
doesn't really cost
anything in network space.
You don't have like
this VLAN problem.
And provisioning new
instances is super cheap.
So take advantage
of that, and use it.
A lot of people have
deep, horrible scars
about asking for a
new machine, and then
having it take
months to provision.
And you need to erase
that from your mind,
and this is a beautiful
new world, where you can
have a new machine in seconds.
So make sure that your
application actually calls
the APIs and makes
that happen when
its necessary,
because it's not going
to be the last time that you
scale up or maybe scale down.
So you need to think
about how are we
going to scale past the
boundaries of the components
of our system.
So VM is one.
Like a Cloud SQL instance is
another pretty obvious one.
Even like a GKE cluster
will have a size
that it can't go beyond a
certain number of nodes.
And there's some strange
scaling boundaries too.
Like in App Engine, you
have a scaling boundary
at your request deadline.
It can't go for more
than so many seconds,
and it can't use more
than so much memory,
depending on the type
of request it is.
So there's a bunch of
different scaling boundaries
that you might have to
anticipate and think about,
but the answer in all cases is
the same-- scale it outwards.
So how do we do this?
At Google, the term
we use is sharding,
and there's a lot of terms
across the industry for this.
And they all describe
the same technique,
which is you take a
consistent workload,
and you divide it up
into little chunks that
can be done independently.
It's just divide and conquer
among a consistent workload.
It's different from the noisy
neighbor scenario, which
is more about different
workloads that were coincident
on the same resources.
This is the same workload
that you can split up.
So if we take our
server, our API server,
and just replicate it three
times, then each one of those
can do 100,000 back
to the Vision API.
Then we can serve our
full 300,000 to our users,
and everything is good.
So we use more shards to
increase our capacity.
So what do you use VM sizes for?
Why do you even have that?
Well, those are really
good for getting best
performance and efficiency.
So if your unit of
work lends itself
to having a quarter of a
terabyte of data in RAM,
then you want to pick a
machine that fits that size.
But you don't want to just
have that unit of work
be just growing over
time as your inputs grow
or something like that.
And sharding is really hard.
It's very difficult to
take your chunk of work,
and figure out how to
make it independent
across multiple machines.
So start super early on this.
And think about it a lot, and
try little ideas and prototype
a lot to get the right balance.
So it takes a while.
But best practice is as soon
as you find yourself wanting
to crank up that instance type
and make it a little bigger,
file the bug to
implement the sharding,
and keep it pretty
high on your backlog.
So after we shard,
we're all super happy,
because we know that every
single one of our instances
is going to get 100,000 QPS,
but, of course, that never
happens.
One of your shards is
going to get super busy.
One of them is going to
have the celebrity on it,
or it's going to
represent New York
or Tokyo if you've sharded
across geography or something
like that.
So one of them is
going to get hot.
So think about, how am I
going to balance that out
after it happens?
You're going to need to reshard.
You can't just hope that they're
all going to be balanced out.
That's the SRE motto, actually,
is that hope is not a strategy.
So how are we going reshard?
Well, one of the
things that you can do
is implement a shard
map, so it's not
a static sharding from the data
to the idea of the node that's
serving it.
It's actually a lookup table.
So you can put
something in the middle,
and you can even use that
technique to get one hot key
and put it somewhere else.
It's more complex, because you
have multiple nodes this time.
So it takes a little more work
than just pushing something
to a single node.
Like you might be
able to get away
with resharding a
single node at a time
while leaving the
other ones together.
And that is what we
call splitting a shard.
This is like the
primary technique that's
like the go-to move if
your shard gets too big
is just split it in half.
This is how Bigtable works.
It just waits until
the shard gets too big,
and then it splits it in
half, and then does it again.
It's not super reliable.
Like if you have one key on
the shard that's super hot,
splitting it in half won't
really help that much.
But it works in a lot of cases,
so it's a good way to start.
One of the nice things
about splitting shard
is you can just do it
just with that one shard,
and you don't have to worry
about the rest of them.
You can just keep
them running, and you
don't have to like update your
global shard map or anything.
So I recommend it.
And if you have a super hot
key, probably resharding it
is not going to actually help.
You probably need to think
about moving that out and making
it a separate workload
or separate subsystem.
Like put it into cache, or
make a dedicated subsystem
that can actually
serve that thing.
If that thing itself
is 100,000 QPS,
you might want some
special attention.
The end of the pretty pictures--
so what we say in the cloud
is that we prefer cattle, not
pets.
And this is just how we think
about the subsystems that
compose our service.
The classic one is a VM.
So a pet is a nice
thing, and you probably
have some subsystems in your
service that have cute names,
and everybody knows
what they are.
And people refer
to them by name.
And if they die, then you cry.
You're very sad.
But if cattle dies, it's
the cost of doing business.
And that's kind of the
way we think about it.
I was always really
impressed when I first
got to Google with how little
tears were shed when a very
important machine went down.
There was just a
script that you ran.
There was just like
throw away the machine.
They would just take the
machine out of all the configs,
and send somebody
in the data center
to go physically fuss with it.
And it made a lot of sense once
you got your head around it
that as soon as you
detect that there's
something wrong with
it, don't try to fix it.
Just get rid of it, because
you have another technique
to actually auto-heal or bring
another one back into the herd.
So pets are often one
of the hardest things
to deal with because of the
human factors around them.
A lot of pets have
like a handler,
and you probably know some
of these in your systems,
where there's a certain
person, and they're
the only person that knows
how to deal with this thing.
And it gets very upset if
anyone else touches it.
And so we leave it alone
until that person comes back
in the office, and
everybody is very scared,
even though they realize it's
absolutely critical for running
the service.
So if you see that kind of
thing happening, where people
are scared to touch
a machine, that's
a good sign that it's a pet.
And also, when you
see people trying
to be heroic around their
pets and be the fireman who
goes and saves the cat from
being stuck in the tree,
that's a good sign that
you have a pet also.
You should just let the cat get
down from the tree by itself,
if it needs to.
There's other cats.
So the best tools I know
for getting rid of pets
are just acknowledging
that there's a pet
and documenting it.
And once you've written it down
that this thing is critical,
and nobody knows how to deal
with it, and when it breaks,
our whole service goes
down, it starts to sink in.
And people get over their fear
and start working on solutions.
So I definitely recommend
writing it down.
You might have experienced this.
Outages often occur when
you change something.
So don't change things, right?
[LAUGHS]
This is the number
one cause of outages
in every system I've
ever worked with is
people deploying something.
At Google, we think of
the config and the code
in our system as really
one and the same.
We don't really treat
them any differently
in terms of how we manage them
in the source code repository.
We put all the config in
the source code repository,
and we do rollouts of config
and code in very similar ways.
It's kind of like
config is just like code
that can be pushed up
with greater frequency
or something like that.
And we treat config like
code by unit testing it
and sanity checking it, just
like you would with code.
So the best techniques
for not deploying bad code
are to have a good way of
recovering when you do,
because it is just
so inevitable.
A lot of the time,
people will try
to fix something hot after
they've pushed some bad code.
They'll try to
debug it and fix it.
And the absolutely most
important thing to do
is have a tried and
true rollback process,
where you just have a
big red Easy button,
and you can just smash
it as soon as you
notice anything going
wrong, while a deployment
is happening.
So precondition for
that is you have
to know when a
deployment is happening.
At Google, we have
a database where
everything that
deploys something
posts a record
into this database.
And so you can kind of
go and look it up and see
if some component is changing
that's related to the alert
you're getting.
And you probably want to
do something like that too.
People do stuff as simple
as like a Slackbot that
just records every
deployment that's
happening to using
something that's
pretty advanced like
Spinnaker, where
you can actually see what's
going on and control it.
But the most important thing
is when Operator A on System A
is noticing that
something is going wrong,
they look at A's
53 dependencies.
They can see which ones
have changed in the past 15
minutes or something.
And it allows you to then
hit that Easy Rollback
button on the right system.
It's not bad to hit a rollback.
We often roll things back,
and then roll them forward
again not much later,
because the rollback--
it was like a false alarm.
You roll it back.
You end up kind of delaying the
progress of the whole rollout
by, I don't know, a
couple hours or something.
But it's a really
good peace of mind.
It's really a good thing just to
get in the habit of like muscle
memory of just doing it.
So once you have
that, and you're
really confident that
your rollback works,
and you just hit
it every time, you
can start to automate your
rollbacks by having something
like a canary watcher that
watches the first machine that
gets your new code and sees
if it goes error condition.
If it goes error,
it just stops the--
just stop and roll back.
Take that machine.
Take it out of the
service, and then you
can do forensics on it,
[? whatever, ?] on the side.
I said canary.
That will probably give the
idea that progressive rollouts
are really a good idea.
So you think about just
sending it to one machine
first, and then maybe 10
machines, and then maybe
a whole zone, and then
maybe a whole region.
And the rule of thumb
that you want to do
is you want to go slowly
enough that you can detect
the issues that will emerge.
So you don't want to
just kind of like run
through those stages
automatically.
You might want to go a
little faster from one
machine to 10 machines than
you do from zone to region,
because you have to give
yourself time to figure it out.
For example, one thing
that people often
do with the global system is
they roll it out globally too
quickly.
Like if you roll
down into a region,
and it happens to be
sleepytime in that region,
and you don't notice, because
all the users are asleep.
And then you go ahead, and
you roll it out globally,
and then the users
wake up, and then
you realize you have a
global outage on your hands.
So just go slowly.
Make sure you have a good
bake-in time for each stage
of your progressive rollout.
But if you need a rule of
thumb, a pretty good one
is to do like a 1%, 5%, 10%,
50%, 100% kind of strategy
to ramp up.
That gives you
enough easy ramp time
in that you'll probably
catch most of the problems
on the first machine.
You often don't know if
it's just the machine itself
or if it's the new
code, but by the time
you get to 50% or 100%, you
can actually go pretty fast,
because you've already
done a few increases.
The main problem
people have with doing
progressive rollouts, though,
is that they don't really
understand whether the
new software is actually
working correctly or not.
And this is because
a lot of people
have monitoring gaps in
their system between what
the users' expectation is and
what the monitoring is showing.
So it's very typical that people
will be monitoring CPU and RAM
usage on a server, put
some new code on it,
and then they see the CPU
and RAM usage change a lot.
And then they kind of wonder
if that's a big problem.
And then some time
passes, and they
decide it's not a big problem.
And then they just kind
of let the rollout go on.
And maybe it is a big problem.
Maybe it's not a big problem.
We don't really know.
But the real test is, did your
users think it's a problem?
So the ideal scenario is if
you can have a monitoring
metric that actually
predicts your users'
opinion of your
service, so it's not
that hard to think about how
many errors are you serving.
Was there a big change in
latency that you're serving?
A lot of times, you'll
add new features
to your service over time.
And your CPU usage
will go up quite a bit
when you put out a new
feature, or it's very common
that a new feature
will have a new dataset
that it needs to pull in.
So you push out
your new feature.
It does a whole bunch of
I/O and a whole bunch of CPU
to pull all the
data in into RAM,
and put it into 40 different
tables so it can serve.
It looks really scary
to the operator,
because you just put
some new code in,
and it does all this stuff,
and you don't understand.
But the most important
thing is, did you
think about exporting a
metric, about the success
of that new feature?
So you can see if that metric
is trending like you like.
So then if you detect that
the users are unhappy,
that's when you dive down
to your CPU and network
and RAM stuff just
for diagnostics.
It'll try to give you a clue
as to what's going wrong.
The most useful
thing you can do is
build these types
of metrics right
into your microservices
libraries.
So in Google, we
have an RPC layer
called Stubby, which gives you
a client stub and a server stub.
And it's great, because
the client stub exports
how many requests it's
making to the server,
and the server exports how
many requests it's getting.
And they have
consistent definition,
and they operate on
similar pipelines.
So they arrive at the same time.
And so you can just make a
graph of how many did the client
send, how many did
the server get,
and it's like dead easy to tell
if there's a network problem.
So a lot of services
I see being built,
people kind of try to
monitor on the side,
or they try to monitor
off of logs or something.
But it's really,
really, really helpful
to build it into your network
client and server libraries
to export these high
level metrics right
to your monitoring system,
so you can really tell
if something's going wrong.
This is the last one.
You made it.
You really need to understand
what are your failure domains.
These are chunks of
your infrastructure
that can fail all
together at the same time.
So obviously, a VM can fail,
and all the processes on
that VM are gone, clearly.
And obviously, a
zone and a region
have-- there are
also failure domains
that we talk about explicitly,
don't even want to think about.
If you know your
failure domain, then you
can do really smart things
like put your backup
in another failure domain,
which a lot of people
kind of don't do
for some reason.
But it's really important
to be thinking about,
where am I going
to actually recover
from when I need to recover?
A lot of outages I've
seen get to a point,
where people are
thinking of, oh,
should I stand up a new
cluster in a new zone,
because this one's down?
And then they start
thinking, well,
which zone should I choose?
This is a decision you
can make way beforehand,
and you can choose what's your
new failure domain going to be,
and where you're
going to recover
it to like way ahead of time.
And put your backups there,
and put all your data there,
so you're ready to go.
You don't have to
make any decisions.
Making decisions when
your system is down
is the worst possible
scenario, because you're all
full of cortisol,
and you're crazy.
So just try to make
as many decisions
as you can ahead of time.
And you want to use
your failure domains
for a lot of your
day-to-day operations.
Like make sure that
your failure domains are
in your monitoring
as a dimension
that you can cut by,
because if a zone goes down,
then you want to see that zone
went down, not just like nodes
one through 49 went down.
You want to use it,
also, in your rollouts.
So you want to roll out
to this zone, and then
that zone, and then that zone,
because if the zone goes down
in the middle of
your rollout, you
want to be able to
be sure that it's
the zone going down and not
your rollout taking it down.
If you imagine if you rolled
out to multiple failure domains
at the same time, then it would
be a little harder to tell
what's going on.
And you want to
actually disaster test
on the edges of those
failure domains.
So we like doing destructive
disaster testing at Google,
and we'll just take
a node and shoot it.
And just like the
Whack-a-pod kind of thing.
Or we'll take a whole zone
and just knock it out,
and see what the operators do,
see how the system recovers.
So it's a good boundary
to think about.
And you can also
make failure domains
within your application
like synthetic ones.
So you could make--
I don't know.
You could have your power
users be in one logical failure
domain, and then everybody
who signed up yesterday
be in another one
so that you can
think about what would happen
if we sacrificed those people.
Would we still be getting a
significant amount of traffic
from the rest of them or not?
And what would happen?
So you can get kind of
creative about how you fail.
All right.
We made it.
So we know all that stuff.
A lot of it is not super
rocket science, and a lot of it
is stuff you've probably
seen before and heard before.
But it really is important,
and it bears repeating.
So how do we actually
get the nines?
Just knowing about the
stuff is not worth it.
It doesn't give you
automatically nines.
You have to act on it.
There are hundreds of bugs
out there, which are just
little time bombs waiting to
go off, because someone knows
that there's a problem,
and they can't really
justify putting in all the
work to fix it right now.
So a good technique
to think about that
is think about the criticality
and the impact of a problem
and how likely it is to occur.
So is it a critical
situation that's
going to take your
service completely down
like if your pet dies?
Or is it something that's going
to maybe degrade your service,
or maybe you won't
even notice at all?
And then how frequently
is it likely to happen?
Is it going to
happen multiple times
during a single
on-call shift, or is it
going to happen maybe once
a month or once a year?
And then you can think about
quantifying how much time it's
worth to actually
invest in these things,
and then scheduling out the time
over several weeks or months
to actually get some of
these bigger chunks done.
There's been far
too many outages
that just went like, oh, yeah,
I knew that was a problem.
We've known about
it for two years,
but we just never
bothered to fix it.
And that really comes down
to just analyzing stuff.
I'd like to remind the
developers that reliability
is the number one feature
of your application
is that it works.
And so it's completely
legit to file a bug
and say there's a
reliability problem,
and have a discussion
with your product managers
about, where do we actually
put this in the features?
Do we put it at the top?
Usually, it comes
pretty much at the top.
I've found most product managers
say, oh, yeah, of course.
Obviously.
I thought you were
doing that all the time.
But it's good to have that
clear conversation about it
to make sure that you
actually get to it in time.
And so these are
things we can actually
anticipate and prevent,
because they're fairly generic,
and they'll pretty much
happen to everybody.
But, of course, we can't
anticipate everything.
So we're going to fall back
on a lot of our SRE principles
and practices to deal
with all those things
like do a blameless post-mortem.
Do your disaster testing.
Do your reliability
reviews by actually-- what
I mean by that is
get the design ready.
Talk about the SLOs and
what are the requirements.
Get a bunch of disinterested
engineers, colleagues
or friends, in the room to
try to poke holes in it.
And make that as
part of a practice.
And that's the way to get
those incremental improvements
for these weird things that
you can't really anticipate.
That's going to be the thing
that's going to take us forward
to three nines and beyond.
All right.
Thanks for your time, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]